we have found the Higgs boson so then
the next question is what's next well
the Large Hadron Collider this machine
that is 2027 miles in circumference
costing ten billion dollars is big
enough to create the next generation of
particles so the Higgs boson in some
sense is the last hurrah for the old
physics the old physics of what is
called a standard model which gives us
quarks and electrons the new theory is
going to take us into dark matter now we
know dark matter exists dark matter is
invisible so if I held it in my hand you
wouldn't see it in fact it would go
right through my fingers go right
through the rock underneath my feet and
go all the way to China it would a
reverse direction and come back from
China all the way here to New York City
and go back and forth so dark matter has
gravitational attraction but it is
invisible and we are clueless as to what
dark matter really is the leading
candidate for dark matter today is
called thus particle this particle is
the next octave of the string now look
around you everything around you we
think is nothing but the lowest
vibration of a vibrating string the
lowest octave in some sense but a string
of course has higher octaves higher
notes we think that dark matter could in
fact be nothing but a higher vibration
of the string so we think that 23% of
the universe which isn't which is the
Dark Matters contribution to the
universe comes from a higher octave of
the string now the standard model which
we have ample verification of only
represents 4% of the universe so the
universe of atoms protons neutrons
neutrinos that universe only represents
4% of what there is 23% is dark matter
which we think is the next vibration up
of the string and then 73% of the
universe is dark energy dark energy is
the energy of nothing
it's the energy of the vacuum between
two objects in outer space
there's nothing nothing except dark
energy dark energy which is pushing the
galaxies apart so when people say if the
universe is expanding they say two
things what's pushing the galaxies apart
and what is the universe expanding into
well what's pushing the galaxies apart
is dark energy the energy of nothing
even vacuum has energy pushing the
galaxies apart and then what is the
universe expanding into well if the
universe is a sphere of some sort and we
live on the skin of the sphere and the
sphere is expanding what is a sphere
expanding into well obviously a bubble a
balloon expands into the third dimension
even though the people living on the
balloon are two dimensional so when our
universe expands what does it expand
into hyperspace
a dimension beyond what you can see and
touch in fact string theory predicts
that there are 11 dimensions of
hyperspace
so we're nothing but a soap bubble
floating in a bubble bath of soap
bubbles and so in some sense the
multiverse can be likened to a bubble
bath our universe is nothing but one
bubble but there are other bubbles when
two bubbles collide that could merge
into a bigger bubble which could be the
Big Bang in fact that's what probably
the Big Bang is or perhaps a bubble
fissioned in half and split off into two
bubbles that could be the Big Bang or
perhaps the universe popped into
existence out of nothing that is also a
possibility and so the universe could
essentially be nothingness which was
unstable and created a soap bubble now
you may say to yourself well that can't
be right because that violates the
conservation of matter and energy how
can you create a universe from nothing
well if you can't calculate the total
matter of the universe it is positive if
you calculate the total energy of the
universe it is negative because of
gravity gravity has negative energy
when you had the two together what do
you get zero so it takes no energy to
create a universe universes are for free
a universe is a free lunch and then you
may say to yourself well that can't be
right because positive and negative
charges don't cancel out therefore how
can the universe be made out of nothing
well if you calculate the total amount
of positive charge in the universe and
calculate the total amount of negative
charge in the universe and you add it up
what do you get zero the universe has
zero charge
well what about spin galaxies spin right
but they spin in all directions if you
add up all the spins of the galaxies
what do you get zero so in other words
the universe has zero spin zero charge
and zero matter energy content in other
words the universe is for free